[Applaudissements]
sera pas que ça à [ __ ] si vous les
questions bien sûr brochure est allé à
l'eva question bonjour je m'appelle
catherine j'ai vu que jean michel maire
avait pris votre rôle d'humoriste dans
l'émission vous devez être bien dégoûté
donc je voulais savoir si vous en
représailles vous alliez prendre son
rôle de gros dégueulasse c'est une très
bonne question à vous poser la chaire
catherine mai mais n'ont malheureusement
je n'ai pas les aptitudes de jean-michel
pour tenir ce rôle de gros dégueulasse
je veux dire la vérité c'est vrai qu'en
reprenant officiellement mon rôle dans
l'émission jean michel m'a bien mis à
l'amant de la semaine dernière à 1
pour être tout à fait honnête j'avais
pas vu arriver en visionnant les offres
j'ai compris que c'était plus proche de
la sortie qu'autre chose pour ceux qui
auraient manqué le début je résume début
janvier jean michel s'est rendu compte
qu'il est mais géraldine jardy maillet
s'est pris un gros râteau donc s'est
rendu compte que finalement il n'aimait
pas gérald il décale et et humoriste
jean michel c'est comme les enfants
hyperactifs faut toujours trouver une
nouvelle activité pour les occuper donc
mardi
khedama place et vous allez voir il a
pris ça très très au sérieux
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour toi la crise sociale
la motion
ouais c'est l'actrice qui est dans ce
livre va recevoir un césar jean-luc fait
rigoler mais effectivement
[Musique]
il
les idées à mesure
ce projet
c'est la nouvelle version du générique
du générique de tp c'est parti jean luc
tu fais rigoler
[Musique]
oh
et où vous aurez remarqué que niveau
camaraderie heureusement qu'à matthieu
delormeau et qui a une passion pour moi
je crois je reviens souvent dans ces
conversations
là par exemple en regardant la feuille
de présence car oui les feuilles de
présence qu'on fait l'émission faut
savoir on nous demande de signer au cas
où ce serait un sosie qui sera notre
place parce qu on ouvre l écran mais on
n'est pas sûr que c'est nous donc en
regardant la feuille de présence mathieu
a révélé ce que lui inspire et ma
signature
bizarre
marché
[Musique]
blaze qui jean mi mai
oui bon
calme et sa rencontre le sniper
priapique et le culturiste déclaré
qu'ils rigolent à toutes ses vagues on a
les deux c'est satanas et diabolo arrêts
du coup jean miche se contente plus de
faire des vannes il juge aussi celle des
autres jeux faciles à manquer mais
maintenant c'est la police de laval jean
marc est serré falloir reprendre les
choses en main si vous avez créé un
monstre de tous les crimes que je n'ai
pas vu c'est le meilleur métier pendant
un match
ce magnifique était un artiste
exceptionnel et je dis ce soir on a été
nuls
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces rallyes normalement les réserves et
complète j'avoue que ce ta gueule il
fait du bien ça va le club et parce
qu'il est tellement sur lui en ce moment
jean michel qui met des vents mais comme
il y en a jamais mis alors celui qui
vient avec valérie je pense qu'il va
rester dans les best of non seulement le
mec dans a rien à battre de ce calvaire
raconte les mêmes physiquement vous
allez voir il fait pas semblant
malgré ce qui se mérite et dé m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l horreur fusée le valérie oui mais bon
heureusement il ya aussi de l'amour dans
cette équipe
mais comme c touche pas à mon poste même
quand c'est un geste tendre on n'est
jamais loin du top gênante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il m'a tout débloquer les cherry on
était sûr qu'à son investigation patrick
termes d'apd investigations pas ce genre
tâche n comment ils font vous regardez
toutes les émissions hypocrite mais les
émissions mais les émissions
[Musique]
en fait
la gamme
[Musique]
isabelle boulay un moment mignon
maintenant on a des besoins et qui dit
mignon il dit évidemment maxime gainey a
oui les minions vient épauler maxime il
veut que nos invités soient bien reçus
s'ils pouvaient ils leur préparer un
petit côté de france au plateau alors le
jour au cyril a proposé slimane de
rejouer une scène de the voice
il n'était pas bien du tout mais
vraiment très bien vous restitue
contexte ciré dia slimane de chanter qui
va lui tourner le dos et si les séduit
il se retournera en buzzant le problème
c'est que tpb vous avez vu un les
besoins sur un peu particulier oui donc
maxime n'était vraiment angoisse parti
je me mets comme ça je me demande si ça
m'intéresse je me retourne ses bases
cette lampe à diesse l'égard de
n'entrons pas de buzzer
pourquoi tu ton nom
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais peur très mal vue on n'y pense
pas à ça c'est pour ça que maxime mérite
son prime 1
même si ça fait pas plaisir à tout le
monde alors j'ai une nouvelle rubrique
si vous voulez ça s'appelle les petits
secrets de fabrication de tpm pm merde
parce que souvent nos téléspectateurs
voient quelque chose à l'antenne mais
ils savent pas la petite histoire qui se
cache derrière ce soir là on allait
faire un gîte crois j'y crois pas sur le
prime de maxime gedi
[Musique]
pour aujourd'hui
et on peut vous
[Musique]
on a le sondage également twitter ce que
vous y croyez
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est horrible j'y crois
moyennement trois maxis et traite
relation retourner c'est horrible c'est
nos rites et d'horreur qu'une horrible
reid
passons à agathe maintenant à agathe qui
qui a un peu galéré cette semaine par la
semaine dernière pour prendre la parole
heureusement vous allez voir elle est
très persistantes sur les poteaux
ces réunions en fait est-ce qu'on peut
résumer l'émission macquinghen efficace
[Musique]
je suis désolé syrie mais il faut
revenir maintenant sur un moment sombre
de tpm pk car le courage c'est aussi
d'affronter des souvenirs traumatisants
des images horribles qui vous font
réveiller la nuit en sueur comme ce jour
où jean michel avait décidé
d'enregistrer un portrait façon amour
est dans le pré pour géraldine maillet
un un moment qu'on voudrait tous oublié
mais bon allez bien que j'alimente tout
ce qu'on n'aurait pas voulu voir et
entendre cette semaine donc c'est tu
fait partie
c'est jean-michel et oui il a été dans
les prés pour tourner son portrait pour
vous à
ils ont très tôt mais là j'aime ton
fibre pas des espions
ses dix fils et mon talent tactique
ouest version célébrités sur gulli sa
survie ah j'adore cette émission soit
quelqu'un qui a pris ta chatte
mais bien sûr aussi l'âme
[Musique]
là
je n'ai pas là bas
[Musique]
mali
cours
qui peut se passer assez vite
normalement
lorenzo
voiture mais comme ça mais allaoui à la
table je ne sais pas mais les couilles
oui
c'est votre avis
[Applaudissements]